I just finished my round eight game
against International Master vigner
vatner Stephenson and it was a good
fight coming into this round I was four
and a half out of seven
and I really didn't have much time to
prepare because
uh my previous round today uh went for
about four hours and there was only so
much time to eat between games
so I went into this game without too
much prep also like I checked my
opponent's games and just saw he plays
everything like this year he's played E4
D4 C4 and I have three Etc so I decided
just to stick with my usual repertoire
and we ended up going into a Catalan
after Pawn to G3 I had briefly looked at
night off or Knight to C3 before the
game but I really didn't look at much
Catalan before the game
and I was aware that he probably
prepared for me and my most recent
Tournament game that I played against
the Catalan was in Abu Dhabi I'll link
that somewhere maybe below and in that
game I played a very rare sideline Pawn
to H6
and if you want analysis of that line
you can check out that video I didn't
want to repeat that line and he actually
told me after the game that he watched
that video and was hoping that I would
play H6 again but I decided to play a a
different line which I actually play
more often is Pawn takes C4 Bishop G2
and Bishop to B4
and I didn't really want to go into this
because it's it's pretty predictable uh
given that it's my main opening that I
play in online Blitz and bullets and
Rapid but
um it's also a very solid reputable line
and he also told me after the game that
he was not happy to see Bishop B4 so I
think I made the right decision and the
line that we went into after Bishop D2
is Pawn to C5
and maybe about 10 to 15 years ago this
line was really really rare but it did
grow in popularity partly due to a good
friend of mine Ray Robson who uh played
this line with really good success he
has some beautiful games in this uh from
the black side and he's one of the
reasons why the Slime became more
popular so I like to call this variation
the Ray Robinson variation and the idea
of C5 is to First defend the bishop but
also to pressure the center and it
avoids a lot of the mainline headline
Theory so from here my opponent played
A3 and he was still in preparation yeah
because he he reviewed this before the
game takes takes and then takes and
takes and black is temporarily up a pawn
here but white has a bit more
development and this Pawn in D4 is a bit
weak so I go ahead and play Knight C6
defending D4 castle castle and then Rook
to C1
and I'll admit that I wasn't really in
specific preparation but this is a line
that I've studied over the years and I
knew that with reasonably accurate play
Black shouldn't be so much worse but
generally it's a little bit more
comfortable for white so I knew I had to
be careful here
so I decided to play this move Rook B8
which has basically one main purpose of
getting off this diagonal of the bishop
because I really want to play B6 or B5
and improve my worst place piece in the
position
um I can't play B6 right away because of
Knight E5 and then there's issues with
my C6 might being pinned
so Rook b8's useful move he plays Pawn
B4 and then I decided to play very
directly and essentially Force matters
play Pawn B5 hitting the knights and
after 95 we trade type Bishop B7 we
trade some more and then after Knight C6
light wins back the pawn on D4 and then
we trade queens and so far it just looks
like a whole trade Fest and it looks
like we're heading towards a draw but
the thing about this position is
it's still more comfortable for whites
and I wasn't actually feeling a hundred
percent sure that I'm okay here because
after I play Rook d8 he moves his Knight
back to C6 and black is under a bit of
pressure here it actually took a long
time on the next move because I have to
be careful of back rank issues for
example if I play Rook to D6 then I'm
already losing the A7 Pawn I can't take
the Knight because mating on the back
rank
so I was debating mainly between Rook 8
and Rook D2 and ultimately I decided to
play Rook D2 and the variation that we
went into is what I calculated uh before
playing this move so he plays Rook D1 I
take takes so I do concede the the D
file and now white is threatening uh
back rank mates I play G6 key checks I
play King G7 and the main reason why I
decided to go into this line even though
it looks almost lost for black if white
plays Rook 8
um just to show this on the board there
is a nice idea here to play Rook to B6
now this didn't happen in the game but
this is what I calculated when I played
Rook D2 several moves back and the point
of Rook B6 is that if white takes on A7
then I have very nice move Rook A6
pinning the knights Now The Rook is tied
down and I'm going A3 pawn and it's
probably only black who can be better
here
so Rook B6 I think would just manage to
to hold the whole Queen side together
and if the Knight moves then either Rook
back or Pawn A6 it should be fine here
so instead of going for Rook 8 he went
for
Pond F3
and then he said something funny after
the game like when he played this move
he was imagining Ben Feingold telling
him never to play F3 and it's possible
that this move wasn't the best way to
try and get an advantage because it
gives me time to play really nice
centralizing move Knight to D5
I think his intention was just to bring
the king in and restrict my knight but
once I played Knight D5 I'm feeling very
happy because the knights has just a
nice Central post and if he plays E4
then I can maneuver eventually to C4 and
Target the weak Pawn on A3 so after
Knight D5 he then plays Rook 2 A8 and
then I played the tricky move here Rook
to C7 at first I was mainly looking at
Rook B6 but then I realized Rook C7 is a
nice little line because if he takes a
pawn I have Knight P6 hitting the rook
and this would actually force a draw
after Rook B8 Knight D7 Knight that hits
the Rook his Knight is also hanging he'd
have to go back to A8 and then we would
repeat so when I played
Rook C7 here I offered him a draw
because essentially I'm allowing the
line with repetition
um but then he he declined which I
wasn't too upset about he played Knight
to D4 and the game keeps going
I play Rook B7 defending the pawn he
plays Rook C8 I play Rook C7 so at this
point I'm just trying to be solid and
make sure that he's not getting any
funny business here I'm offering The
Rook trade and if takes takes I would
defend B5 and yeah this should be just
equal
so he played Rook to Da here he was
really trying to create chances for
himself uh but then I play Pawn E6 and
at this point I think I've completely
Consolidated and I'm already having
ideas of Rook C3 or maybe even Rook C4
first and trying to get counter play on
The Queen side so then he took a little
bit of a think uh yeah six minutes to
play Rook D6 and then he offered me a
draw and then I started thinking do I
play on given that maybe he he lost hope
in his Advantage but then I realized
yeah this position is very very close to
a draw I was thinking about playing Rook
C4 but at the very least I think he has
Pawn E4 which should be equal so I
decided to accept and yeah the game
ended very peacefully I think this has
been the most peaceful game out of all
my games but there were still some
interesting moments with opening
preparation and just the slight struggle
to not be worse going into the end game
and he actually told me that he was
following a chessable course for most of
the opening I think a course by
Grandmaster niranian on the Catalan
so I guess I should be pleased that I
was able to just neutralize his chestful
preparation and uh especially because I
I didn't review this line before the
game
now one more thing I want to do because
I'm really curious I feel like this game
was maybe close to perfect like I'm
really not sure if either of us made any
like obvious mistakes or inaccuracies so
I'm gonna run the engine analysis and
this is a nice feature on me chess for
anyone that wants just very quick
feedback I guess first of all I have to
enable usually when you're in the lead
test study you can request computer
analysis
and we just will do its thing
it is loading the graph
and look at this nice flat line so light
was like
slightly better throughout the game
oh there is one point when I played Rook
C7
engine once Rook takes E7 but this this
should still be a draw I think right
wait what
is better
really
also look at this uh just to show
look at this
96 no inaccuracies mistakes or blunders
but
I could have been worse
I'm confused Knight takes C7
King F2
and I was just gonna bring my king in
Knight C6 A6
King E3
wow the king's getting to C5
I could have been much worse wait what
if I play E5
ooh ah the E5 Pawn is just hanging
wow
okay I guess I'm grateful to not I have
lost this game I could have been
tortured a lot more
um okay that makes me feel even better
about the result
uh man goes to show like I could have I
could have played a perfect game
but still probably lost
just really crazy
anyway I'm gonna end it here thanks for
watching and there's one more round
tomorrow uh and it starts an hour
earlier at 9 00 a.m so I'm gonna have to
get some sleep
um but stay tuned for the final recap
and I'll see you guys later